[Musique]
la beauté n'est pas la même pour tout le
monde vous monsieur par exemple quel
style quel genre de femme préférez vous
j'ai pas de sa porte elle est belle je
n'ai pas de type de femme particulier
mais j'ai quand même une petite
préférence pour les blancs d'oeufs les
petites brunes bah j'aime les très
jolies femmes rendait brunck ont
beaucoup d'alluré en forme poser une
question délicate vous prenez un enfant
un peu animal
mais un vol tam arabe lesbiennes
enchères avec de beaux yeux
je suis assez exigeant j'aime les femmes
belles et intelligentes et naturel que
ça de battre m e jean pinard pas que
c'est plus de monde du management enfin
j'ai quand même le droit d'estimer vos
expressions le fameux pas trop grosse
bien pour cent et la taille assez haut
quel type de faim vous préférez gène à
l'origine à marie laforêt des gens
renouvelle le genre brigitte bardot mois
mais l'andalou ce qu'est ce que vous
regardez d'abord à sa ligne d'avoir ça
le regarde le visage alors regarde les
yeux la silhouette générale les jambes
ya deux choses et cheveux les jambes
n'est pas maquillée beaucoup plus rien à
nous on dit tu es con alors comment elle
s'était les femmes mais les fameux des
commissions d'habitude il payait avant
j'en avais qu avec des grands chignon
mais pas de noir aux yeux penses-tu rien
du tout bon vieux
pour macky tout en mettant qu'il a vu la
photo de la jeune fille la machine
[Musique]